[Music]
this is Lottie Reineke the unsung
heroine of early animation this amazing
woman pioneered early filming techniques
in Germany but her achievements remain
largely unknown as a child Lottie was
fascinated with silhouette puppetry she
cut a hole in her dining table snipped
perfect puppets out of paper and turned
her house into an animation studio she
had a very distinct style and filmed the
puppets having great adventures her
early work got her accepted to an
exclusive group of artists where she met
her future husband and creative partner
Karl [ __ ]
it was Lotte Reiniger who invented the
first multi-plane camera in 1923 this
groundbreaking filming technique
involved layering sheets of glass
underneath the camera to give the
illusion of depth she used her
multi-plane camera to create the first
animated feature film in color the
magical and hypnotic Adventures of
Prince Ahmed in 1926 this innovative new
technique was studied closely by Walt
Disney he then made a more sophisticated
multi-plane camera which he patented as
his own Studios invention Disney
released his first feature film Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs in 1937
over a decade later due to the power and
influence of Hollywood it's widely
believed that Snow White is the first
animated feature but it's not true
when Hitler and the Nazis took power in
Germany Lottie and her husband fled the
country they continued to make films
with anti-fascist undertones dotting
between different countries until their
visas ran out when they were forced to
return to Germany she had to make films
for the Nazis to survive eventually when
the war was finally over
lotty settled in London she loved
animating fairy tales for children like
this brilliant adaptation of Thumbelina
she spent the rest of her life making
over 40 beautiful animated films
when Lotte Reiniger died in 1981 her
genius was still little-known
overshadowed by the fame that Disney
enjoyed it seemed her achievements had
been written out of history but if you
look carefully many secret homages to
her work can be found in modern films by
people who know the truth
[Music]
you